Nó này 1 táng 12, 2 năm 2018, thông tin từ công an tình quảng chiếc.
Đơn vị đã gió quy định tạm sữa hình sự đối với với nguyễn án bảo chiến,
sinh năm 2020, chú phần bà đồn, tình quảng chiếc để đưa tra về hàng viên
của ý về thương thích sẫn đến chết người.
Trước đó, khoảng 12, 2 năm 2020, 2 năm 2020, 2 năm 2020, tạc quảng viên à sky Bí Lieb Lắp Khafe,
Tổ dức phố 2, phường bà đồn.
Phạc anh quý, sinh năm 2020, chú phần bà đồn, tình quảng chiếc và chiến gió phát sinh một tối cả nhân đến đã sẻ ra sĩnh nhất.
Số sát, hậu quà, chiến bị thương thích nhẹ, quy địa thương nọn,
giới vào trạm thái bất tình và được đưa đi cấp thước đến chứ hôm sau khi quy tử vong.
Ngày sau khi tiếp diện tổ ra, công an phần bà đồn đã hình chương tiệt thành đồn bộ các bị pháp đưa tra,
sắp mình để làm só vụ việc. Ngày mùi chiến tháng 12 năm 2020,
các quan kẻ rất đưa tra công an tình quảng chiếc đã ra quy định tảng giữa hình sự đưa với mến ăn bảo chiến.
Hình các quan công an đang tiếp tục đưa tra, con có ổ sơ, sử liên nghiêm bởi tượng theo quy định pháp lật.